The objectives of fasting is the topic
today. And I'd like to begin by asking
you exactly what are the main objectives
of fasting.
Alhamdulillah.
There are many objectives of fasting.
I'll just list the main ones. Number one
is seeking the pleasure of Allah
subhanaa tala. Number two is
to obtain tawa to acquire tawa that is
god consciousness piety righteousness.
And you can say when you acquire tawa
but natural when you learn tawa
automatically even the pleasure of
Allah's month comes in it. So the first
one can be included in the second one.
The third is
for entering Jenna. We fast for entering
Jenna. Number four is for the expiration
of our sins.
Number five is to seek the reward of
Allah subhana wa tala. Number six is for
the forgiveness of our sins. If we fast,
Allah's forgives our sins. Number seven
to acquire a shifa. That is the right to
intercede. The right for intercession.
If we fast, the fast will intercede on
the day of judgment for us.
Number eight, it is
to realize the bounties of Allah subhana
wa t'ala. Number nine, to increase our
willpower and our determination.
Number 10, it is to acquire good deeds.
Number 11 is to gain more honesty.
Number 12,
it is to decrease
our desire, diminish one's desire.
Number 13, to narrow the passage of the
Satan. Fasting narrows the passage of
the city.
Number 14, to act as a shield. Fasting
is a shield for the believer. Number 15,
to abstain from false speech.
And number 16, to abstain from false
actions. These are the major objectives
of fasting.
>> Oh, Dr. Zak regarding that introduction.
And we should be covering all of those
uh subtitles today inshallah. I hope